what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation I see you you see me we're gonna watch
a movie called I see you how did we stumble
upon deciding to react to this well it's a
horror movie and we've been loving covering horror
here and it's number one on Netflix I was like I
don't know what this Phillips I've never even
heard of it it's not a Netflix original it's
an actual movie that made its way to number
one so we said we're watching it today who
knows maybe it'll become a segment where we're
just like what is number one on Netflix let's
watch it ladies and gentlemen if you can see us
please go ahead and leave a like you know you'd
love to do that also subscribe and click
the notification Bell because we covering
more movies these days as always full length
Reaction watch along three sync up with your
own copy available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page thank you all who joined we got so
much crap over there that you would love to fill
your minds with crap Galore is what we call it
and I think that's all all right let's watch this
and see what's going on thank you for being here
ah Dairy d-e-r-r-yah
damn this kid does his own stunts
yeah he trained a long time for this
actually Insurance almost wouldn't let him do it
watch out for Bears my dude oh cool shot yeah
whoa
gnarly geez
I love this I don't even know
what this is a Rotten Tomatoes
[__]
sounds like a Trent Reznor score
this movie is weird I love it so far
is that Helen Hunt is it I don't
know I can't tell I can't tell either
do you need money for school
do you want to connect with me as a
person here's a hundred fifty dollars
get yourself a hot lunch so when
you start sleeping on the couch
keeps on passing out in front of the TV not that
I blame you mom's a [__] so are you getting into
fights now they're being [__] that's no excuse
don't defend yourself to have the other kid alone
the other two kids one of them cried it pooped
his pants good audition scene both of you
I already I'll see you later that's my
name whoa is this like your marriage whoa
is like my marriage are you kidding me
I thought we got bulletproof windows I
thought we installed the three inch thick ones
oh you on my lemon drink did he put the mug up
there yeah just a spider you're an addict 10 years
old went missing on a bike ride last night near
Jupiter Park just letting Michael came Michael
King was abducted cycling to a corner store in
the city not Michael Kane you lead on this got it
not Roadmaster any longer
I feel like there's a like a large demonic
presence it was like an overlooming shots
they keep happy like Zach thought yeah it's
like if you took the Evil Dead POV and just
made it really ominous and slow in just everywhere
it's literally like something is closing in yeah
oh what a messed up ghost it's
like the camera's a character
just a window repair man I'm not gonna hurt you
I'm sorry who let you win a kid of yours
very polite you you trained her well
who I would not just uh let that go
yeah I would follow that guy outside
I want answers I went fast I want to know
where that kid sleeps I wonder where he
eats or nobody gets his bike wheels from
Jesus Christ sir should we bring it in
yeah you can uh you can beg wow there hasn't
been a pocket knife in this town in 30 years
you remember cool Gardens before you're
taught oh of course I remember the green
knife or Gordon is yeah I got help put in that
he ain't good now so what do you think copycat
foreign
that with a plastic fork little
girl little girl ghost could be
who died yeah yeah Green pocket knife girl ghost
screw repairman okay you're angry how
could you do that answer the question
oh you don't get to call me that you think
pancakes and fancy dinners are gonna make
it up no you ruined our family and
you should [__] pay for it well
our nine-year-old Michael King went missing just
okay that repairman they sent out I think he
stole from us you what all of our silverware is
completely gone he said something strange about
some girl I don't know what's wrong with him
he's not that sudden me for cheating he's upset
about the boy what that repair man stole the photo
ironic artwork Ambien that helps calm
the anxiety hey how'd you get in here
where are you going oh there's something
terrible about to happen to this animal come on
I heard you whoa Wowie
yes but let me out now
Connor that's not Connor it's unresolved trauma
heard pounding so I came up he's out
I have no idea what's going on in this movie
you know it's like all the tropes with none of
the traditional tonal build up yeah I have
no clue I know you can't just forgive me
but I want you to know I'll do whatever it
takes to make did you want to get married
you really think we'd still be
together if you hadn't gotten pregnant
I'm trying Greg it's hard being a Greg seems like
it man I had no idea what you had to deal with
whoa
a little late to be playing video games isn't it
it's a little late to be cheating on tattooses
what in God's name is that
night
she has a weird false reassuring way of
delivering her lines hence the counselor
manipulating you but yeah I feel like she's
not actually saying what she's really feeling
what is what is happening in this movie
like stuff's Just Happening
whoa bust out them rubber sheets that's
embarrassing you're a drunk cold gourd
emo was an exact match of a serial
child abductor you put away 15 years ago
you said what they still had on hand Jesus I
sent Larson to track down the two boys that
escaped Braun and Travers but they might
remember details now they could help him
beat Gordon's defense I interviewed both
those boys extensively when it happened
why'd you end up with us Ray huh he
got too close to the truth Tommy Tommy
absolutely terrified of these tummy guy
he ain't never been the same I still
have that brontosaurus you gave me
whoa no no no no no no no no no
what
how is this all together this is a
secret Slenderman movie or something
after the little house just the magic house
it means you're never gonna find him ugh
are they living in the magic house they must be
I'm still not sure if this movie
has these what is happening whoa
hey what are you doing dude it's Sam Merlot
last time because that was a whole
different because I'm in love with you
oh no no God I don't want to be with you
scared Todd stop what we have you know
whoa I was gonna say where's Connor at God
you're the worst kind of person to have
an affair with loud and show up yeah
no discretion whatsoever you want
to get caught ow ow ow ow careful
something about the walls as soon as Connor
goes to school I think I should take you
to the hospital this is a terrible situation
yeah he's gonna stab him with that toothbrush
kid plays every moment like I'm in a horror movie
how else would they know how to feel you're
calling me did you leave your phone somewhere
oh
uh
get in the car I'll be right there someone's
in the house or something and they're killing
children and leaving pocket knives you can
tell me I won't be mad I just wanted wowie
I'm so sorry my son is out there Greg is going to
find him go Greg got this keep that stapler close
Michael watches out his childhood window
what are you looking for oh
that was scary yeah chances are I knew the kidnap
he grabs him drops one of the
knives to throw us off maybe
solid Theory or stops the kit
no one's found that yet this is so well hidden so
well camouflaged sorry it took so long I didn't
yes a complicated situation of being
classic jump scare
explained that we were over and out of nowhere
it just fell why didn't you call an ambulance
I don't know that
so angry he tried to kill someone
no no you don't get to lose it right now
do you know what will happen to our son
I won't be able to protect it you
gotta take the fall for this I the
body put a green pocket knife on it
go change out of those clothes um
this is fascinating there's like
two very definitive different
stories happening here and they both feel
equally Bleak and yet somehow so disparate
and detailed yeah and I'm like how is this
connected exactly other than the characters
Good Fellas
nice practical lighting for an ominous tone the
movie has really good music yeah they even insert
like a slight child voice there like a little
giggle or something yeah like little echoes
oh the photos are gone did you see
that whoa what I was so engrossed by
the the shapes of everything but yeah
that wall is completely blank damn
silverware oh is it all in her head
is it that movie or his head it's
always one in one of their heads
oh that's very human barrier yeah the
grab a shovel and help me or hop in
I feel like I should know
it I don't know frogginess
is this like a furry thing
but for amphibious types
what like living in the walls
hey Connor you want some pancakes
so they were actually under the bed yeah well it
can't be in all their heads because they were gone
sure this this makes more sense let's send a kid's
head it could be he was there the whole time so
foreign
holy [__] whoa
oh no stop for anything I'll
call you when I'm on my way
mine's Jackie I've gotta find the
son of a [__] who did this drive
watching you even now damn this
is a great streaming movie yep
perfect for Netflix and chilling yeah
I see you to hang those back up why'd they take
all the photos that was for us the audience
make a lot of noise and you can't really call
for backup in this situation because
you'd have to explain where you were
that's mean foreign
symbolize yeah I'm like is it one of
their songs is it the themes of the lyrics
yeah you gotta get him out
of the street to defeat him
no turn around he doesn't deserve
to die no he doesn't deserve this oh
interesting nice cut
oh
okay and now it's a VHS movie
go IndyGo
it's a fridge what the hell
never seen a fridge before
they actually ex-military
is that just a military bag
you gotta be kidding me I'm not
are they also killing the kid
what I just doesn't try to connect I
feel like this could be a red herring
this is loud
oh interesting
so so this is like only worth it
for this part of the day quick
I can't see anything night vision
so turned on right now
Nice Nice Shot this movie's
got nice restrained drone stuff
it's like a weird rashamon that
this guy overstayed is welcome
fun at all
I know the word oh catch up to you BJ oh yes
sir yeah that's actually that fits perfectly
they see the Book of Revelations
happening outside that'll rain
you idiot
bastard seven-letter word starts with B hmm
mission accomplished there's so many places
to hide your down there if we need a Quick Escape
that's our route yes I care about that wouldn't
it be kind of funny to mess with them take
some random [__] make them think they're
going crazy two days this guy went crazy
she really took the assignment to Heart
just a second just let him in he
doesn't know you don't live here
and then she became an accomplice
on top of already being a criminal
oh what'd you put in the pills
dude I would have bailed on this with this
kind of guy yeah just leave the house now
don't even tell him her kid got swiped
last seen wearing a green soccer jersey
went missing in Troubadour see one of the
kids who survived or something come on
I'm not gonna hurt you Connor you mean to tell
me when Helen Hunt came over here she wasn't like
why is this door locked with this with a freaking
hockey stick yeah you failed to mention that part
oh okay okay oh God
oh my God
sicko
that is too far man yeah
as
it was odd
and what's the point
I mean it please you gotta ditch this guy
you should push him off the roof okie dokie
maybe she'll just bail right now she's got
to be the one who's warning Connor though
you do what yeah leave
wrong choice of words you should have
just left he should have just left
it's cleverly orchestrated
the way they did this uh
no
what no what are you doing
Jesus oh I wonder if you go back and if
it was in the shot yeah probably I wonder
yeah if you can spot them in in various
moments maybe yeah yeah that's clever
how does she end up hitting him
we're in this together now yeah or
is she just gonna witness this yeah
just messing with their sanity man
twist upon twist wow
oh my god oh that's gnarly oh [__] everyone's
kind of fighting this woman movie got me there
yeah me too that's good that's that is a solid
development that clinches a lot of things I think
so is he the guy with the green pocket knives then
wait was it their stuff that he just
put in the trunk like they get it was
his maybe she had like a like a camo what
did you put in the trunk that might just
have been a different duffel bag with the
bat in it sorry it took so long I wasn't
oh my God why didn't you coordinate
those why didn't you call an ambulance
imagine having all this
knowledge the worst position
Barbara really came for her
it's hilarious damn
what's up with this guy there's like a
sadness is he like the evil twin that
they separated at Birth I mean like he has a
personal motive against the family and maybe
I mean that that's my convoluted Theory my
other theory is just like maybe he's got
some weird family trauma that this is bringing up
or something like he kind of like almost crying
get up there's so much going on in this house
no I am not gonna let you ruin just
for free oh yeah oh damn it that
it's this house
come on look at button button keys
always in such close proximity
he's like punishing this guy
no
oh God and to wind up with him
she must think he knows this is so convoluted
but I wouldn't happen any other way this is
so cost so stacked with [__] right now it's an
overlapping Venn diagram horrible human nightmares
of course
he's the guy so he is the guy yeah
why would he be doing it I
don't know is a serial killer
I would just be like on the ground
no hello hello can you hear me
you're becoming dumb stop put as much
distance between you and that car as you can
don't go toward the light
perfect opening
foreign so you can see down the hole no no
help us oh it's them
it's gonna be okay come on
no I liked you I know it's not my
type so I'm taking it back to town
it's going to be edited and everything yes
you weren't concerned when your kid was kidnapped
who's copycatting in my own damn house
that's interesting you are I was scared for
him like 40 minutes ago yeah I was scared of
him other guy's pretty awful but damn and now I'm
just hoping that this guy maybe steps up and takes
him down he's gotta have some connection to this
yeah it's probably like someone's brother wake up
everybody should put a little makeup
all I need you to do is stand up okay
treated like an intruder just stand up
don't do it
needs to make it look like he caught an intruder
now it's a Vengeance movie yes the woman
I thought I killed was killed me yeah
there was an ax in the garage
yes assume your final form
consequences man do you have another gun
almost Devil's Rejects like yeah and
then the flip-flop between who's who's
the real bad guy yeah who's gone too far
for real where is the line squatters man
it's like the less tortury
version of The Collector
it's a fun experiment in perspective
this movie it's a fun ride
led by Helen Hunt in her finest role
yes opposite not quite Dennis Quaid
come on come on Frogger oh do it for the kids
oh because he chose the house too right yeah
come on Frogger come on buddy
come on Helen Hunt walk in
nope up not be done he done
come on you got one more twist up your sleeve
stick The Landing don't make me hate this it's
more like a Saw movie no yeah in some ways
this really reminds me of the collector
which is itself is and he came here to terrorize
Elite detective on that case she tied up his son
he was gonna be next I stopped you just
in time he shoot me you're shooting a cup
you have any idea what's coming
for you please be recording this
please yeah he was a victim you don't
understand huh when I was a little boy wow
oh no whoa that was a shoulder
clip right I believe so
oh my God he was an undercover cop
here's my bachelor
observing this man for months
on end To Catch a Predator
oh he got rid of the bull
oh yeah I was like please no
put the raw Man Behind Bars
see you had every right to cheat on him
Should Have Cheated it was good that you did
foreign
yeah the jersey and all that
it's a little bit like prisoners too
let's not give something I want to say
it's High Caliber no not as much of a film
otes
wow
his hair was black
Yoshi he always had the Yoshi yeah fun
last line is Helen Hunt going what the [__]
faster black don't just think because Dad's
a cellular killer I forgive you for cheating
laughs it's a principle that counts
yeah where did this come from and why
didn't I hear about it how did he get so big
what's going on we're gonna look up some stuff
box officemojo.com this movie make any money
was it released in theaters um it
made like a million dollars okay
um not a lot but it's good to see that it's like
picking up on streaming I mean it's like a perfect
movie to see on stream yeah yeah totally all right
before we look at the Rotten Tomatoes score for
any of this yes um no I enjoyed it it it started
off in a way that was like okay this feels like
one of those low budget mystery thriller movies I
can I can feel the restraint on budget and they're
doing more with their camera work and as much as
I was enjoying it because it had a bit of not as
ugly or nasty but it still had like I haven't
seen collector um but I've I've seen all the
Saw movies and collector is about a guy who breaks
into a house because he's desperate and then finds
out that it's a Serial Killer's house in there
basically like Saw traps inside like the song the
team who took over Saul wrote it and directed
it oh okay yeah well this movie um I was like
all right I'm not sure it did a great job in
the first half of it of okay is this like an
immediate real crime Thriller is it Supernatural
like I couldn't tell what was happening because
it was so questioning of how is the the story of
a of a of a family with this affair situation and
this cop who is coming off the heels of dealing
with this affair now investigating this mystery
of a missing child tying into whatever
crazy Shenanigans are happening at home
um and then they did the thing where it uh they
changed plot they changed right and I was like
okay hold the Barbarian now we're seeing it
from the perspective of the people who have
been living in the home and at first I was like
interesting and then I started going well maybe
this is not as it's kind of undercutting some
of the attention then it just started getting
[__] crazy yes and then it started getting like
really then then we reached impressive like I it
was a combination of this is ridiculous to this
is impressive yeah because once they laid out
that especially the fact that it is purposeful why
this guy is here because they're pitching him as
he's the serial killer they did a really good
job on uh when I said when a reference Devil's
Rejects of making you go ah they're the victim
no wait they're the bad guys I don't know who
to fear for yes I don't know who to root for
I'm actually working for the bad guy now uh he
was in a bag he actually wasn't a bad I mean
he's unnecessarily torturing the rest of the
family but that is to torture the main guy yeah
of course to torture the cop um which I thought
was great it had a real cool mood I mean like a
bigger budget they probably could have allowed
this to be more of a dread heavy film sure you
know like I think that was it when you're saying
prisoners I was like yeah it was a little bit
more like deliberate and Dread heavy and or this
was moving like this moves fast yeah it's it's
enticing though like the whole movie is enticing
and it has a really great like what the hell is
going on factor to it and then when they and I
like the midpoint of it because because it's like
we're telling you what's going on but there's so
much more to uncover yeah as it keeps going and
I thought that was great because I thought ah
you're revealing it a little tour early and and
then they because like even when the girl dies
um oh when he thinks he killed his friend
yeah uh he seems concerned it's not like he
just snapped you know yeah he's not completely
immoral yeah so I think the last half of this
movie is like very impressive on how they handled
it because it does whenever you think the movie's
done telling you it's tricks and as you're
just watching you know the answer you're like
oh no there's more there's more to discover
about the reveals right up until the very end
um so yeah I mean like because you were saying
you said like you feel like there's something more
personal with him and I was I didn't quite pick up
on that right away but when you said that it made
me go maybe he's one of the victims yeah and so to
see uh so it was a good tag team effort there in
the mystery well done with well done but the but
but yeah I thought it was I thought it was well
done I thought it was really well done um would
have liked some type of resolve with Helen Hunt's
character and the child because that is the first
half of this movie and then they kind of just go
well she learns that's done yep and uh there's
just gonna be left to pick up the shards of their
broken lives I guess yeah because it it's it's
more I I thought it was I was really looking
forward to seeing how this all pays off yeah you
know um because I like the idea of especially
looking back in retrospect that him killing the
guy who she had an affair with that was probably
the thing that allows him the sense of closure to
be like come in here like I inflict the trauma now
on you yeah and then and then he's like and she's
saying I'm sorry and then he holds her you know uh
yeah it's so it's probably in his mind is is how
retribution happens for the situation yeah yeah oh
is is nasty um yeah but I still would have liked
a little bit of a little bit of Retribution but it
is interesting it starts off like Affair and
how is this gonna like is this an emotional
turmoil that Center to this point and I like
that they didn't make him a copycat but that
he was the original killer the whole time which
just makes the whole plot even more ridiculous
it's a little that's a little silly it's a little
silly but I like it it's a perfect crime like lead
investigator is the guy like okay like I can
see why that would work but it's also on top of
all these other circumstances yeah it just feels
so high concept it's like lead investigator was
the guy the whole time yeah and that's a Saw movie
thing that's yeah that's what I mean it isn't that
it's it isn't that this guy snapped because as I
thought okay maybe he snapped because of Affair
and and that and now he's become copycat guy you
know like is is that what happens but no control
all this time he's been the guy yeah which just
makes me he was like sillier to me sure sure and
while you know he's got compensate for being
gifted this beautiful house and this beautiful
life and you know he's got to feel like uh
he's getting control somehow yeah yeah yeah
uh yeah this this was yeah a really fun and uh
unfolding sort of experience where like yeah at
the top you're like is this about to become like
Blum House hereditary or something and I do like
that at the end of the movie like yeah you have
the cheating element like they set up all these
very classic tropes of like oh you know dad's
trying to kind of bond with the kid and like
there's been a marital Affair and they're just
trying to get along and so at first you're like
okay we're getting this kind of standard issue
drama to flavor this weird WTF experience so yeah
like at the beginning it feels like a haunting
movie or something like that or yeah some kind
of weird strangers thing and so you're like okay
Bloom house meets a24's creep dread Less in your
face style but then yeah the the it reminded me
of multiple movies definitely strangers and and
definitely like I said The Collector but at the
same time like the execution and the ultimate
like placed it landed felt very kind of fresh and
invigorating and unique to this even though yeah
and prisoners is in there too like there are so
many things that clearly learn from but I thought
it made for this really great ride that they
really for the most part it's like you know did he
how did he know that the boyfriend would get there
and then time his you know ride with his partner
to go get that file so that he could kill him like
they're little things like that where I'm like
okay how does some of the logic work but for the
most part uh yeah the the game of perspectives and
just the ever it's deepening hole of nasty sort of
psychology uh yeah just like I think it's all kind
of brought together by that stuff it's like it's I
I'm always kind of open to and welcoming of a sort
of what the hell is happening experience but it's
up to the movie to know what it's doing enough to
bring all that together to make that worth its
while and here I thought it was like here I at
the beginning of the movie or part way through I
thought okay this is this is gonna feel like a a
less fresh and interesting Barbarian or something
where it's like you have this weird tension at the
beginning and then like a complete uh reorienting
of the stakes and circumstances and all that and
then you've got this like balls to the walls
payoff whereas here like I thought it really did
nicely to again transcend that you know comparison
Point into its own sort of Twisted journey to
where like yeah at the outset it feels like okay
this uh detective is trying to figure out a serial
killer case while also being tormented in his
personal life uh but then at the end of the movie
you just realize like oh no the movie's about this
kid who escaped this guy's clutches ultimately
takes his revenge and brings him down and so like
it's cool to start with one line log line and end
on a completely different one yeah and I thought
it was neat too because the the movie did a good
job on selling me that he's a psycho and I do
appreciated that with the frogging thing like part
of me then at the at that moment was like okay so
you read up on frogging and you're like I'm gonna
make a cool frogging horror movie where people
think they're going insane is really just people
living in the walls but even that's been done and
so it's like it took a bunch of these familiar
styles of story they're all very like in the
Zeitgeist and managed to build them into something
kind of Primal and classic but that also like
really nicely you know purposes those uh you know
kind of current elements in a way that's very sort
of satisfying and still sort of current feeling
that's interesting on um I wonder why this because
this this article is from March 11 2022 does it
have anything to do with the movie I see you I
don't know maybe I mean no it's not even mentioned
in this article huh it's a thing that like um yeah
has been kind of an Internet urban legend or there
have at least been reports of yeah people living
in other people I'm just trying to I'm trying to
see if like if yeah no no I'm saying that it is
for this article to be published in March 2022
when this movie's it's number one trending in
March 2022. this is a responsible third article
low budget but it's not but I'm saying like maybe
people are looking at frogging that led to like
them discovering this movie sure like the concept
of it I've heard of like squatters I've heard the
term squatters and squatters doing this kind of
thing was like so there's all there's concepts of
squatters where you can't be living secretly
in your home or you could just you know be
dicks about it but yeah this is like squatting
with a game element yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I don't know who would document this [__]
I know that's the stupidest part of the movie to
me is like why would you doc you didn't even need
the documentation side of it yeah I feel like you
could have just had them recording just because
it's like they needed an excuse to that's part
of the weakest part of the scripting to me I was
like you you yourself are saying this is illegal
weekend so what are you gonna do with this footage
yeah and why are you trying to disseminate it to
help other people do it too when that would only
kind of serve to like help people recognize when
it's happening yeah much easier you're putting
your face on camera you're talking I'm like this
is a terrible idea lady why would you do this
you have a cell phone and everything yeah keep
the masks on and do it like maybe and that could
necessitate The Mask a lot more than just sort
of a random Motif that matches the activity yeah
uh that was the silliest part to me and it seemed
like a part that they included so that way they
could have the moment where the cop goes over the
[__] they don't be doing [__] in my house you
know when I'm like there's other ways you could
have gotten there yeah it feels like something
out of a VHS movie yeah it was once there's a
one part because I thought other than that like
I liked the the actress a lot uh whoever played
the main Frogger I thought that she she was great
and I love this situation that she was in I just I
just loved how it just kept getting stacked which
is more ridiculous I really liked the last half I
enjoyed the first half and I really liked the last
half a lot the last half was yeah was when it gets
the it I feel like that's when it really Embraces
what I want to be and I feel like it would make
for a fun re-watch to see if you could ever see
these hidden spots I loved how they play with the
perspective on you're going back to the previous
scenes that you saw in the first half and you
could see where they were the whole time and it's
believable yeah that you couldn't catch them it's
it it's not it never the movie never made me go
how could they not have suspected that there was
someone living there or how could they not have
seen they made that very plausible and how it
played out and I thought the way they handled the
reveals too was great like like when the cop hit
um Sam from True Blood when he when he did hit
him in the basement with the bat you know you
it you're immediately thinking it's the guy
she's frogging with yeah and then the way the
camera does the reveal the like from starts off
on the dead body and then pulls over to the left
you're like oh [__] yeah that's the copy like
sure oh this is wild did he just kill him or is
there something to do without it has your mind
going and right up until the end and I thought
that was a lot of fun I thought they had a lot of
fun I would have liked the result though because
I have a very clear plot because it's like you
have two plots in the beginning of this movie
you have the fair family situation right there and
there's someone stalking me in this house what's
going on at an investigative mystery and then they
kind of completely drop the other one yeah and I
guess the movie's saying that's resolved with
the guy being dead and the they made amends by
hugging it out at that moment you know yeah as the
movie's saying that's when it's amended and I feel
like there was a little bit more to it that they
kind of just dropped but but I also do appreciate
they get someone like Helen Hunt in here
where like what is the poster for this movie
um is it just her looking you know what I remember
I'm gonna play this at like 1.5 speech it's like
super super quick on my end the ICU trailer and
just to see if they like watch the giveaway like
did they lead with Helen Hunt in the trailer I'm
just gonna play like super super Speedy just to
get the visuals for it but I'm not gonna play it
on screen um yeah 1.75 speed let's go through this
yeah they're mainly leading with the first
half and they're mainly leading with Helen Hunt
um yeah yeah the sort of yeah yeah yeah so I think
that's smart like you leave with Helen Hunt in the
in your build up and you feel like she's the main
character and she's gonna be going through the
torture torture stuff is just happening because
of her so I think it's smart in that way who's
who's like it's more impressive than I expected
yeah I had no expectations I was more like what's
this random movie trending yeah totally no it's
it's like tight and clever and and it has that
sort of disorienting quality and it manages to
earn that too yeah yeah it snakes between being
different kinds of movies and uh yeah like there's
something about the way that they just commit to
her that does it's like the two female characters
in the movie ultimately are sort of exonerated of
a lot of things even though they are you know
guilty of certain parts of the web of you know
uh mess uh and so yeah it's like because Mindy
dies and that's a real bummer uh I feel like it
could have been nice to at least compliment
of like okay Helen Hunt lives and also maybe
we just get some kind of emotional payoff for her
because she has been so manipulated throughout
this whole situation uh and and I mean Mindy has
been too to an extent I mean for obviously better
reasons but yeah thematically it would be I guess
it's not in the movie's main concerns but it would
be nice to have and for this one too like I don't
know something other than just like okay they're
gonna come home too an even worse yes subversion
of their entire lives What Becomes of the sun who
like already hates this [__] out of his mom yeah
and and who you know has at least had some kind
of uh comfortable Rapport or some some you know
Refuge with his dad yeah you know who's now had
that taken from him on top of being in a situation
where he thought he was being kidnapped by the
actual serial killer but he wasn't but it turns
out that that's his dad anyway so he might as well
like there's there's a lot of interesting
stuff there and part of me wonders like I could
if this had done better I could see how this could
turn into some kind of weirdo franchise but but
yeah I guess man it's getting it's it's number
one on Netflix sure no I can random low budget ass
movie that barely made any money in the box office
is is like suddenly killing it and that's really
cool like it's cool to see it yeah yeah it's cool
to finish one of these and be like wow like while
this is like the perfect Netflix movie because
too if you're watching your house is gonna get
you thinking about every little sound you hear but
also the kind you would talk with people I think
this is the kind of movie you would be like trying
to guess with your buddies if you're watching yeah
yeah you know yeah just wait just wait you won't
be able to put it together and and uh yeah it's
one of those movies it's like very gratifying
it's like people use the word Hidden Gem a lot
but I feel like this is a good example of that
it's like yeah this didn't do huge when it came
out at first but I hope people start to talk about
it because this seems like it should be it's good
enough to exist in the conversation with your
recent Barbarian and other things like that you
know Smiles or whatever else like I probably
I probably liked this in some ways more than
smile at least I would I don't know if I would I
don't know how exactly it's a barbarian I think on
production wise like there were parts of it
production wise that definitely felt like
um like especially in the sound design when it
came to like dialogue moments where I could where
I felt a little bit less like I don't want to
I don't know if the right words amateur is it
amateur film is I wouldn't say is more of these
sound is on where you could feel a sum of it
where this is still like big early filmmaker you
know whereas a movie like smile sure is while that
follows a little bit more of a traditional it's
more Blockbuster even this yeah this that I'm
talking just on the filmmaking side but if I were
to learn like these guys got another movie coming
out it'd be interesting to see how they step
up their game in terms of just the crafts from
inside of because they they go crazy a little bit
with like the cinematography of these long drawn
out shots and going through the houses and these
overhead drone shots and a little bit of these
landscape moments and I'd be curious to see like
okay now how they up it with their DP in the next
one to really just give it that extra Edge yeah
of not just like Saban films is that is actually
not bad company and then sometimes they come up
with things that are extremely low budget Lo-Fi
you know and so once in a while it's not the
greatest thing or you could tell this is very
amateur filmmaking or low bud or something that
you know the The Bargain Bin kind of example and
in the beginning I was going I guess this is like
right above that in the beginning of this film I
was like I guess it's like right above there and
but then it became something much more that I
thought was actually impressive and it did remind
me of the days when saw first came out sure you're
getting all this like influx movies of things
they call torture porn and this was not that
genre of what they even associate with that genre
but it kind of had that like B-movie flavor well
yeah yeah kitchen sink pulls like all of the
different kinds of dread from all the sort of
popular subcategories and just packs them into
the same movies yeah because yeah it's like you
feel like you are watching it you're watching a
psychological torture no matter which way you're
looking at it in a sense because everybody's
situation like no one's situation is in a
status quo or in a state of uh you know just
like existing Beyond anybody else like every
micro uh relationship is experiencing some kind
of weird turmoil and then the macro situation
is even more messed up yeah and uh yeah I would
so what would you rate before we look at Rotten
Tomatoes which I have not seen yet what would you
call what would you be your percentage rating uh
like you know like a 7.85 wow 7.8 I was
gonna say 78 that's funny hey 78. yeah
it's like pretty solid I don't know see
that's the thing is I think but like an
18 is a b if you're going by letter grade
so I don't give this one yeah like no I'm
going by percentages 78 is the majority of a
hundred yeah it's like pretty damn good rating
it is fun yeah no like I think if I was on
Rotten Tomatoes I saw a horror movie had
78 this is pretty cool very good horror movie I
guess yeah yeah yeah yeah um I had a thought but
it Escapes Me Now I'm gonna I'm gonna click
it I'm gonna see Moment of Truth sure whoa
whoa it's right I guess the tomatoes yeah
that's so funny yeah an audience score
not too far behind wow I had no idea yeah
wow we were like we were pretty much like
right on the money we're a little higher
than them but yeah it's it's kind of funny
what is that what is the consensus I see you
gets tripped up in its own narrative contortions
absolutely put a solid gas and an effective
blend of scares and suspense makes the slow
building mystery worth watching absolutely agree
100 yeah I just think it's so funny how we were
like right right if we were lined up with Rotten
Tomatoes pretty well that's a solid consensus
right there yeah also just real quick props to
because you said the thing about the sound and I
was like yeah part of it that made me wonder if
some of these droning uh score elements were to
cover up Let it give way to just like crazy ass
music that said really like the music and I also
thought that like props to the location scout
because they got so much out of this house and
and the house also has to be able to sell it so uh
yeah as well well uh conceived and yeah executed
overall well they didn't do too much exterior
like the wood stuff they did but that's I feel
it's kind of easy to find those locations Main
Street yeah in the car the police station yeah
so they didn't really change too much but it
doesn't make it I don't become like hyper aware
that we're we have in left locations that often
like I would just feel restrained yeah it doesn't
feel like they couldn't afford to leave location
yeah it's like it's so much involved with this
house and then when you go like really far out and
you find like the the camper van where he's got
his you know kidnap victims like that feels like
it's really out on the fringes of everything yeah
um yeah that was uh that was a nice surprise
yeah well done America well done elevator guys
leave your thoughts down below what did you
think of ICU did you predict all this stuff
did you hear about it via Netflix and watch
it or have you heard of this movie for ages
yeah what does the trailer even have 20s
1.4 million views three years ago it's kind
of crazy to see this movie just [__] it's
nuts I'm sure they find it's awesome I'm sure
there's like I'm gonna type an ending explain
I'm sure there's like some big videos on that
yeah I found foundflix has one from two point
that's 2.3 million views I wonder if any of these
channels maybe helped really actually helped
expand the visibility for the movie because
I don't know there's only that one huge video but
at the same time that could be enough to you know
start that little wave of people finally checking
it out and recommending it yeah because I could I
could definitely see this being a movie people
would want to talk about I mean yeah I I to me
when something goes number one on Netflix
I go audiences must be enjoying this yeah
and sharing it guys leave your thoughts down
below and hey let's send this for the pain
Chase Gardner come break into the studio and
live in the walls I think you you know you're
very active on the patreon giving us support
and whatnot you're also very active here on
the YouTubes and I feel like you know if anybody
could create the right amount of tension in life
by moving things around but also maybe leaving
little things to encourage us that would be you so
you could get your jollies off making us question
our own sanity but then you could also reassure
yourself that you're a good person by leaving
us things that will enrich our lives somehow
and then you can also start your own channel
teaching people how to do exactly what you just
did to their favorite YouTube channels and then
everyone's helping each other Thrive and succeed
and then you can start your own patreon and then
get paid to break into all sorts of other people's
houses so uh Chase I don't expect any credit for
this idea just keep your pledge going and we'll
see you next month and every month until you die
in the closet over there love you buddy love peace